in this video I'm going to share some
tips on how to deal with loose skin how
to tighten up your skin and to do it
naturally so you could hopefully avoid
some of the surgeries they do or more
invasive type treatments now what
exactly is loose skin well your skin has
been overstretched to the point where it
has not come back to its original form
it's like taking this rubber band and
stretching it out but the rubber band
doesn't come back to the original form
so what is going on with that well
there's two main problems a problem with
your collagen and also a deeper fiber
called elastin which is supposed to give
the collagen some elasticity and so the
question people have is should I just
start eating more collagen that help
typically it is not a lack of the
consumption of collagen that causes this
problem usually this problem comes from
getting older losing a lot of weight can
produce loose skin excessive sun
exposure going through pregnancy smoking
has a risk factor being a diabetic can
give you a lot of loose skin or even
going through a lot of stress can create
a lot of breakdown of these collagen
fibers so let's just dive into all the
different component parts and the things
that you can start doing immediately
let's start with hormones okay you have
two different sets of hormones you have
those hormones that build up your
collagen and elastin and then you have
hormones that break down the collagen
and connective tissue within the skin
and the main hormone that does that is
cortisol and cortisol is an a catabolic
hormone which means it breaks tissue
down it breaks proteins down and
collagen and elastin is protein so of
course you have the stress component
that activates cortisol on the flip side
you have hormones that are do the
opposite they're anabolic hormones like
growth hormone which is also everything
about anti aging and burning fat but
growth hormone has a very specific
purpose into helping
proteins grow muscle collagen connective
tissue
Etc and there's three main ways to spike
growth hormone number one high intensity
exercise training
with specific emphasis on intensity the
more intense you do this exercise the
more stimulation of growth hormone
you're going to create so what would
that be well
sprinting hopping on some type of
elevation that's called Plyometrics spin
bike anything that involves intensity
but the key is keeping it short so you
don't over train thus high intensity
interval training right so you're not
going to do a sustained high intensity
you're going to do short bursts of high
intensity with lots of rest in between
so you might rest for two three four
five days making sure that inflammation
and that recovery is happening also what
inhibits growth hormone is glucose so
this is why you need to be on a low carb
ketogenic diet now the other important
factor with growth hormone is getting
enough sleep which also crosses over to
helping you with the stress so if you're
trying to build up growth hormone and
you're not sleeping it's going to be a
huge problem if you have a problem
sleeping you probably need to watch some
of the videos I have down below
regarding that one topic but in this
video I'm just going to cover all the
different points and then you can see
what you need to focus on later this
next thing is very interesting there's
another anabolic hormone anabolic
meaning building up proteins and that is
insulin insulin induces or triggers new
elastin
remember that type of connective tissue
that allows the elasticity in your skin
to keep it like a rubber band well
insulin triggers that which is
fascinating because you would think just
the opposite because you're probably
thinking diabetics well in Diabetes Type
you have a situation where you have
insulin resistance you have a lot of
insulin going through the body but not
in the cells because the cells are
resistant yet the other parts of the
body might have too much insulin with
diabetes and insulin resistance which is
the majority of the population you have
a situation where you have an insulin
deficiency which could definitely create
a problem with insulin so how do you
correct this and get more insulin
you basically fix insulin resistance and
you do that with the ketogenic diet
intermittent fasting and you also do
that with exercise now the other problem
with insulin resistance is it blocks
your ability to get fuel get nutrients
and receive amino acids so the very
building blocks of protein that you need
to build for collagen and elastin are
going to be inhibited when you have
insulin resistance so ultimately part of
this plan has to include fixing insulin
resistance to be able to then pull in
these amino acids and also prevent
atrophy which is a loss of muscle all
right the next thing I'm going to talk
about is related to collagen and elastin
there are cofactors there are nutrients
that help the development of collagen
and help the creation of elastin and the
most important cofactor okay is vitamin
A and I'm not talking about what most
people think about vitamin A which is
beta-carotene which is the precursor I'm
talking about the active form of vitamin
A retinol which only comes from animal
products right like egg yolks cod liver
oil fatty fish butter versus spinach
which has the beta-carotene but that has
to convert into the active form and a
lot of people don't convert very much of
it Unfortunately they they change the
definition of vitamin A to mean both the
precursor beta-carotene as well as
retinol but they're two completely
different molecules so vitamin A is a
really important cofactor for building
up collagen in fact all of the fat
soluble vitamins are really important in
your skin and so this is why going on a
low-fat diet is very bad for skin Health
here's a diet that I came across while I
was in practice people were doing this
diet called Ideal Protein right
well was it ketogenic yes it was low
carb but it was also low fat typically
the healthy version of the ketogenic
diet is not low fat okay it's higher
amounts of fat in moderate protein in
this diet it was low fat low carb and
the protein that was recommended were in
these packaged foods like soy protein
isolates so you have this lean process
protein that they were giving these
people and what I noticed a person in
this program
they just look older with their skin the
skin look very unhealthy they look like
it aged it was dried out it looked
wrinkly and so did the hair so you can
tell a lot about what's going on
internally by just looking on the
external part of someone's body and the
more low fat you do the less fat cyber
vitamins you're going to have and your
skin needs a good amount of fat the next
cofactor that's really important in
collagen and elastin especially is iron
but not your regular iron the heme iron
which is the more bioavailable iron
which is in red meat it's in shellfish
it's not in vegetables that's the
non-heme form of iron you need the bile
available form so just the fact that I
mentioned these two cofactors tells us
what kind of diet you need you need to
do animal products that are not lean
okay that are a bit more fatty to get
both the retinol as well as the iron
that you need so if someone is going to
do a plant-based vegan diet they better
figure out how they're going to get
these key nutrients I'm not saying it's
not possible you can do it it's just a
lot more difficult unfortunately a lot
of people do plant-based end up eating
too many grains to omega-6 fatty acids
which just filled their body up with
inflammation and worsen the situation
all right the last cofactor is vitamin C
and I want to mention something about
vitamin C vitamin C well you probably
heard that it's connected to your your
collagen but most people are taking the
synthetic version of vitamin C it's not
the type that comes from nature so the
best way to get your vitamin C is to
make sure that you're either doing a
food-based concentrate or you're doing
foods that are high in vitamin C and one
of the best foods for that would be
sauerkraut sauerkraut hands down has
more vitamin C than any other food it's
like 10 times the amount of vitamin C
that our bodies require but but you can
also get vitamin C from peppers from
berries things like that the next topic
is exercise
is a necessity but make sure you don't
over train when you exercise you're
creating new vascularization it's called
neovascularization and you're getting
new blood vessels where you're carrying
more nutrients and more circulation
which is what you want to do you're also
going to build up more muscles just
underneath the skin to fill in this Gap
that occurred from the overstretching of
the skin so it will fill up the space
and give you a nice appearance that
there's less loose skin and of course
exercise will stimulate the growth
hormone if you do the high intensity
animal training and then there's
prolonged fasting okay prolonged fasting
gives you what's called an epigenetic
effect on skin because you're putting
your body into an autophagy state where
it's recycling old damaged proteins and
let me explain old damaged proteins
when someone has insulin resistance or
they're a pre-diabetic or a diabetic
they have a lot of glycation going on
what is glycation well it's a situation
where you're eating too many carbs and
this protein is combining with the sugar
to make the protein unavailable so a
diabetic has a lot of glycated proteins
and that's how they measure it in A1C
for example is a situation when you have
this average blood sugars for three
months so we have this interaction
between a certain amount of sugar with
your protein in your blood and it's
creating damage okay and you can measure
that with this test and you can see how
much or how little you have of this
glycated effect but that damage or
glycation effect also happens in the
eyes and the kidney and the arteries and
the brain and the nerves all over but it
also happens in the Skin So if you have
glycation going on in the collagen and
elastin it's going to make that tissue
unavailable and it's not going to
stretch and be elastic anymore it also
happens in your arteries too which can
lead to high blood pressure
so the cool thing is that you can get
rid of some of this glycation by doing
prolonged fasting like three days or
longer when you do that your body starts
to clean up this damaged protein and
recycle it and rejuvenate it so that's a
really cool thing that you can do and
the next thing is part of the last two
things I mentioned which is basically
you're creating a a hermetic effect
which you're adding a little bit of
stress to the body to cause the body to
adapt and become stronger so prolonged
fasting gives you hermetic effect so
does exercise but there's other things
too
like heat in cold putting ice cold water
on your face
and then putting warm or hot water in
your face back and forth can create this
harmonic effect and there's some
interesting research on that which I'll
put down below creating this hermetic
stimulation of your skin cells and
causing the tissue to tone but again
that's for loose skin on the face but
what if it's on the rest of the body
well then you're going to have to do it
for the rest of the body now I want to
mention something about Sun for a second
because too much sun is very bad on your
skin and what I mean by that is if you
expose to the Sun to the point of burn
but a little bit of sun which is the
point before you burn is a good thing on
a regular basis because it creates a
hermetic effect that can actually
stimulate healthy skin but that also
depends on how much melanin you have the
color of your skin and if you're very
very fair complected you're going to
burn very easily so that is the other
variable you have to watch out for so I
covered a lot of different things that
you can do to improve your skin right
now pick one or two of them and just get
started and keep working on it over time
but out of all these points I think the
most important one for your skin would
be prolonged fasting now I have a video
on this which I also include an
additional thing you should do if you
have loose skin if you're doing
prolonged fasting and that is taking
certain amino acids so that way
you're not going to really break the
effectiveness of your fast because
you're not eating like protein per se
you're eating the building blocks which
is very low calorie so you can get the
benefits of fasting but also get the
benefits of the amino acids that can
help build this connective tissue and
elastin and I put that video up right
here check it out